so they're there to kind of things
topics I'm gonna talk through the first
is basically what UX is and that UX is
more than colors there's a misconception
that it's just kind of icons or font
choices and I'm trying to show a little
more context around that and the second
is on the user research side which is
around asking why and not what so
definition user experience design or UX
is creating digital experiences that
meet people's needs and I think one of
the the graphics that I find pretty
evocative for communicating what UX is
or just the set of screenshots because
these are all clear and understandable
at at this scale you don't really need
to know the details of what's going on
here to be able to make some judgments
about the flow between the screens so
I'm gonna share kind of two examples
here and this is the the counter example
to prove the point that user experiences
more than icons and colors this is some
screenshots from a few years ago of lock
icons of the Chinese mobile Internet so
I don't speaker read Chinese so many of
these you know products are kind of
beyond me this is an image shared from
Dan Grover who'd worked there and I
think that from someone that comes from
an organization that really works on
supporting secure communication tools
and things like end-to-end encryption a
lot of these live lock icons don't
really convey much meaning because it
gets into questions like what's your
that model and as a designer I can make
a lock that has two states and one state
is open and on click it goes to closed
if you'd like it can even make a little
sound and and that's not hooked up to
anything that is completely a cosmetic
change so instead of these kinds of only
superficial color and font and logo too
I want to get into some of the the kind
of deeper examples of behavior and how
to communicate behavior to users so the
reason that I feel that this is a
critically important topic is that I
believe in the mission of many open
source projects but I am concerned that
some of that good work is limited and
impact because people often don't
understand what's going on so the user
experience designer shape the
understanding people's understanding and
influence behavior that if the interface
doesn't make it clear that how something
works
people can aren't going to use it so I
think that developer first software can
often be be very kind of elegant from a
behind the screen code point of view it
may have a lot of features but a lot of
the kind of nuance and an elegance of
what those features can do is lost in
that last kind of bit to communicate to
end-users how stuff is supposed to work
so this is an example that I consider
kind of the opposite of the lock badge
icons that aren't that meaningful so
this is from these are screenshots from
messaging apps they're taken from an
iPhone and just at this this scale I can
see that
as an iPhone user I get green speech
bubbles or blue speech bubbles in the
iOS native messaging client depending on
if my messaging partner is also using an
iPhone so that's just some information
for me about kind of what's going on
with the other person but then read
receipts I think are an example of how
UX clarifies some complex functionality
in a very very simple way so in the iOS
messaging client you get words a couple
of characters read at a time or
delivered whatsapp the messaging
platform has a convention that some
groups opt to you
check marks to issue read receipts and
that check mark is an example of a UX
decision that I think is pretty
effective it works all around the world
I don't need to know if my messaging
partner is on Android or iOS I don't
need to know if they're on Wi-Fi or the
cellular network I don't need to know if
their telecom or AT&T or ours or any of
these global service providers it just
works
but the thing that makes this
interesting to me from a UX point of
view is that it changes behavior so an
example of a functional description
would be a different messaging app may
say we issue read receipts but if the
way that you get to a read receipt is
you long press on the user's name this
the sender's name and then get to the
message menu and then you type in
message ID you know equals 0 53 because
it's your 53rd exchange and it returns
status is 0 or status is 1 that is
meaning that maybe the functional
requirements of issuing a read receipt
but it's not going to change behavior in
the same way so paying attention to the
presentation of information
another example information architecture
what you put on menus this is a very
important way to help people navigate
what is going on with with your product
how to make it discoverable to other
people so one kind of quick way to get
started is to look at the menu structure
and put them on post-its and look at it
and a common thing that happens
particularly in open-source projects
with distributed contributors is your
team structure shows up in the menus and
in some cases that's totally fine and in
other cases that might not be quite so
helpful so in one example I'm not going
to you know kind of name the team that
worked on this because I don't want to
point them out for the purpose of
shaming them but it was just interesting
that when when I looked at this tool
that was targeting people that wanted to
shoot live video
as a kind of a news source via two
different kinds of parallel structures
one was templates and the other was
something like examples and the
templates team was different than the
examples team and that was sort of why
they had this kind of parallel structure
but as a user that that's not really
helpful to me there was so much overlap
between those kinds of things that I
didn't really get how they were
different so one kind of really clear
pragmatic thing that you can work on
with a team is a style guide this might
be something that you used to codify
what you already are doing the choices
you've already made or it could be
something that you would want to hire a
designer to produce for you and I know I
think that the Tor project has recently
put out there style guide or a design
worked on that simply secure how to
played a part in it as well and I think
that's actually a pretty nice example of
showing how a style guide isn't some
kind of like top-down police decision
making about how everything must conform
it's actually a tool to concur Ajmal r2
contributors and more distributed
contributions over time because you have
a little bit of the rules of the road
you have agreement on exactly what the
the hex color for your different fonts
is going to be and that can be a way to
help people do something consistent so
in the physical space at the top colors
are a bit washed out but at the top you
see or what it's intended to be a
Starbucks cup with they have an iconic
green color that they've taken the care
and attention to get that color all
around the world different inks
different papers different continents
they've really made it clear that that
kind of color stands for something and
it's what they are so it's the one sides
flummery of this so far you access more
than colors and icons it's these details
that shape understanding and influence
behavior so the next kind of chunk of
this is around user research and asking
why and
what said it's never too early to get
user feedback even if you're at the idea
stage different methods work for
different phases of the process so
that's kind of thing one to keep in mind
and the second thing is if you do user
user research and sit down with someone
they aren't going to tell you as as a
developer like what to do they're not
going to give you advice they're gonna
talk about their own problems and tell
you what they are trying to do I
recommend in-person observations with
people using stuff wherever possible
this is me in the field kind of learning
about you know how messaging works some
people who are power messengers and when
you get the opportunity to actually sit
side by side with people and look over
their shoulder it can be an extremely
effective extremely eye-opening way to
to get feedback but even if you aren't
going to go talk to people outside your
organization my QuickStart tip number
one is take what you have and print it
it's not that I don't like trees it's
that something kind of magical happens
when you print things and pin them up on
the wall similar to you know over the
course of you know my speaking career I
could proofread something so many times
a presentation but somehow once it's up
on the screen behind me really large
it's much easier to find the typos all
of a sudden it's just kind of the way
that things things work sometimes and
when you print something out you're able
to decontextualize it a little bit make
it a little bit unfamiliar and it'll
give you a sense of fresh eyes that it
may help you already start to answer
some of your own questions like wow
there's really a lot of stuff going on
under this one menu and like why are we
calling this this and how do these
screens relate and that's a UX activity
that you can do with only a screen
capture tool in a printer and start to
look at look at the structure and see
what you see a second quick start tip is
if you're unsure you're stuck you're not
clear on how to move
forward with the feature what are good
ways to do things take an example that's
out there now particularly a popular
example so I don't support the values of
every kind of mass mainstream software a
product that's out there but I can say
that in general things with very large
user bases are usable so if millions of
people are able to use something you can
look at them as an example for how to
present things in a way that a wide
group of people a global audience can
navigate this is a screenshot from jitsi
which is a no video conferencing
software and this was part of an
exercise to kind of give get some
comments around how to communicate
values to you to end users how do you
explain the benefits of your your
product and then finally I would like to
encourage you all to think not only
about the product that you're building
but also the companion pieces that
support how you talk about it and this
is pretty controversial to show at a
venue you know like this that's so
committed to open-source but I thought I
would take the risk because it's late
and hopefully everyone is a bit relaxed
so this is an example from a website
where I mean we'd ask people to
highlight parts of it that they found
confusing and one of the things that
came through very consistently this is
in the context of people who use the
file sharing services and cloud-based
storage and in this case there was a
really big emphasis and a really big
kind of open-source love pride and
leading with open-source as a
differentiator for why to use their
product and not any of the competitors
in that audience and in this case really
didn't understand that so I think that
as a community there's a lot of work to
do on how to communicate what makes open
source software special to a mass
audience and in this case this claim you
know open source software anyone can
read the code and confirm that it
doesn't have secret backdoors makes a
ton of sense this person actually
understood
to mean something more like I'm expected
to check the own coat might be code
myself even though I don't have the
skills to do that and the sense was that
open-source was too much like
crowd-sourced
and that it was just gonna be like the
whole community the people that didn't
really know what they were doing we're
going to somehow contribute and build
something so that that actually you know
isn't really consistent with the message
that they wanted to convey so I'd like
to you know give some some positive
praise to least authority an open source
distributed file system and you know
they have done you know a bunch of work
on the UX side particularly you know in
their grid sync product around kind of
security education and a lot of the way
that they've done this is through this
paper prototyping method and having an
end user sit down and walk through a
stack of pages printed out screenshots
while they think aloud yes of course
it's real software but sometimes it's
nice to do it on paper when you do it on
paper you can pull things side-by-side
it can be a much easier way to kind of
talk about what the flow is and many
people who've been to school are quite
comfortable if you give them a piece of
paper and a pen to make some notes and
in some circles and things that are on
the screen can feel so formal and
finished especially to people that don't
write code themselves can be a nice way
to get some some feedback so this is a
extremely quick and basic way to make
like wireframe so these are screenshots
from the Twitter app on the mobile phone
and in this case I'm actually holding a
printout of the screenshots in a window
that's backlit with a piece of plain
white paper over it and that makes it
very easy and possible to to trace over
them so that you can start to see these
kinds of things so the magic that just
happened here is these are printouts
that I traced in the window and the
result is
something like this where I can now
start to call out at the right level of
abstractions what are the menus named
what are the different things that you
can click on how is this structured and
this is the way that most UX designers
learn how to do projects designers that
don't work on a dedicated product team
all the time they're gonna find
something similar and print it out and
do this kind of exercise in order to
kind of get clear on what the structure
is and this slide was a bit out of order
but I'd also like to give some
recognition to the tails team I'm the
simply secure blog my colleague Eileen
Wagner recently wrote up an interview
with their team that talks about some of
the work that they've done on their UX
UI sprints it's an open-source operating
system for people with high security
needs and they kind of give some
developer kind of perspectives on that
so those are the two kind of chunks of
this this talk you access more than
colors ask why not what and to conclude
I'm just going to reiterate user
experience design deal details shape the
experience and if an interface has
technical features in the UX is
confusing people won't use them it's
actually even potentially more dangerous
than that because open-source
contributors may enjoy the ability
knowing they have the ability and the
power to check the code but most people
are making judgments on the quality of
the engineering based on the quality of
the UX by most people meaning a kind of
mass audience so by way of conclusion I
would like to say that simply secure org
we have a knowledge base with a bunch of
different topics
there are blog articles on a kind of a
range of things in the UX plus security
space including more about how to get
going in UX and an in user research as
an educational NGO we work for you so we
welcome your feedback on what to
prioritize if there's an article or a
resource or a topic you were hoping
would be addressed and it wasn't please
let us know and with that I will say
thank you
these are different ways to reach out to
us if you're interested in joining our
public slack channel these are our
twitter handles in my real email address
so thank you very much
[Applause]